in this video we'll talk about how to
use google cloud pub/sub to enable
real-time developer notifications for
your subscriptions for more information
about how to set up google cloud pub/sub
go here unlike the Google Play Developer
API which requires you the developer to
send request to Google cloud pub/sub
works the other way around sending
information from google to you when does
this happen any time a subscription
entitlement changes such as subscription
renewal cancellation or if the user has
entered a grace period or account hold
with real-time developer notifications
you'll receive a purchase token directly
from cloud pub/sub anytime there is an
update to an existing subscription this
purchase token doesn't contain the
details of the change so you'll need to
send the purchase token from your secure
back-end to the Google Play Developer
API to get the updated information
attached to the purchase token once
verified you will have the revised
information about the subscription which
can be stored on your back-end server as
well as sent to your Android app if
needed to ensure users have access to
the appropriate in-app content and
services
and that's it by enabling real-time
developer notifications you are able to
stay up to date on your users
subscription status if you'd like to
learn more be sure to visit the link on
screen or check out our other videos
here